basic weapons and uh a little bit about
cyto senses so this is a little bit more
of just thoughts that come to me and
some of the things I say I may have
repeated in other films
but sometimes repeating is good because
it means that it's not just made up I
said it years ago and I'm still saying
the same today as I used to think about
pensity when he repeated something perap
10 years on I knew that uh it must have
been firmly set in his
mind a few years back I've been thinking
about making the certification for the
Baza the weapons and uh back in when I
was following s centy he decided that
the
world didn't know the weapons what he
called the the Obama Ken and
Joe well enough and he wanted to
certify uh some of his top teachers
around the globe to
instruct and um make sure they were set
for the future for when he passed on he
would know it would leave him in good
hands for us to pass on the corness that
e to
us now
he did stop doing this but uh that was
because of more of a a family dispute I
believe from what I remember but the
principle to me was not for him to make
money out of it because he used to take
many hours uh taking part in preparing
the mocu Scrolls that you'll see in the
background uh you'll see at the
top there I have the the four
Scrolls now I do hold the five Scrolls
and um they've been witnessed that I was
awarded them while I was
in but sadly uh like all of us such a
sense he was a human
being he would rather drink heavily and
because he would have such a a tight
schedule in the daytime either teaching
anyone uh especially in the summer
months you'd be teaching 4 hours a
day but if you done the weapons testing
over a perod of days or weeks while he
was in a such as myself then he would
stay up late at night and
um and hand write each mocu scroll and
so they're very personal to each and
individual now uh
on my fifth scroll and final scroll that
gives you the the degree to hand on uh
to others this knowledge and also to
hand on the uh I decided not to hand on
moku Scrolls because I can't like
Japanese and they pieces of paper um and
they you put glue on them you add
another piece of paper and you just keep
doing this and this is what he done
until you get to the end of the scroll
with all the things that you've passed
and his thoughts and his words telling
you what stage um each part of this m
scr
is I decided to just do the
certification so I award Bui Wasa
certification
now when I started I I decided I would
have the students in front of me me on
seminars or special seminars for the for
these uh weapons
testing but I found that like in most
Dan D tests people would expect you to
tell them the result of the end of it
and I said I can't do that because I was
filming it normally with two camera
angles and um I would riew these films
afterwards and what I do is I put them
on the slowest
resolution and I found that I couldn't
take less than at 78 hours for each
person this led me on and because I was
new to
it even though I've been looking at
weapons for now over 50
years um I decided that it's better for
people to send me in from around the
globe um the their filming of two
different angles this way they don't get
they're not expecting an instant result
I
then uh set time
aside and I look at the slowest possible
speed detailed by detail at each and
every single subur each and every point
that they
do and even though it's very very time
consuming um
there is a cost to it and it's not all
about money but I remember C Sense he
spent to me
once uh Tony don't give your art away he
said you spent thousands he didn't say
pounds he just said you spent thousands
following me around the globe obtaining
his knowledge he said you don't need
translation you just need your eye
and and absorb and remember what I've
taught you but for that it has cost you
so much money please don't just give it
freely because after all a professional
person should charge for something or
else it has no
value I I wanted to say that because
these uh buuk Wasa certifications are
not a low cost but if you want my
51 nearly now years of
understanding I'm I'm a shean u that
means master degree but in the fifth
mocu
Ro uh that also
means like a master degree that you can
that's my interpretation that you can
then hand on to others your
knowledge this is what I'm trying to do
now some people will not like like what
I'm about to say but once I started
doing this I noticed that some of the
high ranking teachers decided that they
would test people as well for the
weapons um they view them they tell them
the
answer I don't think you can do that
because yes you can see that they're
okay but the fine detail is incredible
once you slow a film down and you see
how how incorrect we all are we're all
human beings we all make mistakes
nobody is incorrect like sense he said
he even saw sense he many times made
mistakes so please don't think that
we're going to all be the perfect
student the perfect
teacher so I'm offering the Bui was
Scrolls for one purpose and one one
purpose only to keep Cy senses and those
senses weapons sacred and as clear as I
can give them to the world and as
accurate as I can give to the
world I'm happy for people to send me in
their
films you don't even have to pay at
first you could send me in the film I'm
happy to look at
it and then you can pay if I think think
that there's uh somewhere we can go by
adjusting your uh your
Corrections so I'll just go back a
moment to why I I've got four M Scrolls
not
five I was in ama it was in the summer
we were about to go from AMA to Italy to
England where I was holding a seminar s
Pini was holding a seminar
and so said because he done these late
at night the mo Scrolls he said he was
tired and he didn't want
to um do it while he was tired because
he would s all through the night you
know in at least late into the night he
often said he would be past 2:00 W in
the
Scrolls so I paid him the
fee he promised me it we came to England
sorry we came he came to Italy I was
with him came to England I was with him
saw him back on the playing he
never I never saw the fifth mckarus
role even though I'm an adult I feared
asking my
Sensei it's a strange thing to say but
all I have is the memory of getting
it and
I have got witnesses one
Japanese person who who's still keeping
contact with and an English student
but at least I know got them so this
allows me to award
them so what I've now decided to do is
after looking at several people from
different countries it's very difficult
to
explain in words and pict pictures so
what I do is I look at their film I stop
pause it I do a I cut a piece of the
screen shut out that is incorrect I put
it in the email with all the other
pictures I've just done one this
morning with over 20
pictures of weak points points that need
polishing points that need looking at I
put them in
words but what's brought me to make this
film this morning is that
realize that words can be taken
incorrect or correct but so I'm going to
start making films of even more detail
than I've ever made before they're going
to talk about
how then when I say then that means when
I was younger and now and what I've
learned the things we do back then and
the things we do many years on differ a
great
deal a lot of um people they like to
see flash fast Dynamic
weapons and I totally agree that this is
great fun and it's wonderful to look at
but we must look at the basics the
basics hold
everything if you do fast care and Joe
you need to be accurate the detail fine
detail needs to be
accurate so there will be a series of
then and now and I hope you'll be to
there to enjoy them I hope you've
enjoyed this small
introduction we never get it all right
in one go but my legacy
as I get older is to pass on what I've
learned from cyto Sensi following him
for all those
years and yes 51 years of
iido I believe that if you wake up in
the
morning before you go to bed at night if
you haven't at least thought every
single day of those 51 years like I have
about aido in some segment of the
day
and that's the difference between doing
it as a hobby and as fun and trying to
do it as a martial artist a true martial
artist a martial artist isn't born a
martial artist we're born human
beings there will be no two iama
teachers no matter what they're learn
the same their body shapes are different
they will think slightly different but
the basics of
accuracy must be the same if you're
going to cut to the center of the head
it must be the center you're going to
cut to the side of the head the Yan must
be the side if you're going to cut the
wrist you don't
stop 30 cm away from wrist you cut and
cover the wrist
enough say that was 10 15 cm past it you
don't cut and end the can in the middle
of the whist so the fine detail when you
go to cut the neck you don't stop here
you cut through as if you're cutting the
the head off these details will be in
the films that I make and I will give
you as much detail as
possible if you want speed get the base
it right first and then allow speed to
come
naturally thank you for your time and I
hope you've enjoyed what I've got to
say I'm a very blunt person is the
English word and the Americans call me a
very candid
person in other words I say what I think
may be very
judgmental lots of people won't like it
but I'm seeing so much
absolute crap and that is the word crap
being taught by high ranking
teaches shown such a senses weapons and
those senses
weapons I'll say more cyto sens his
weapons because he was more detailed and
accurate and vast in what what he gave
us but the rubbish that's out there
today is going to loot your armor
weapons not help them my job is to give
you as accurate as possible what I
believe s Sensei taught me and a few
other students who were dedicated to
learning them piece by piece in the way
they should be they won't look the same
as me our body shapes are different we
think differently I'm dyslexic so I have
to segment each piece
the way I said
it
so if you wish to criticize me that's
fine but please look at the films
first make your own
judgment and then you decide because
it's your iido journey not mine I'm
having mine thank you for your time